16 Jahre ist es jetzt her dass das
letzte Mal ein Überschallflugzeug also
die Concorde Passagiere superschnell und
luxuriös von A nach B gebracht hatte
Flugzeit New York London dreieinhalb
Stunden irre jetzt werden Pläne für
mögliche Nachfolger der Concorde immer
konkreter schon 2035 könnte es
Schätzungen zufolge weltweit rund 2000
dieser superflieger geben kriegst du
mich Science Fiction hier gibt's täglich
spannende science Videos abonniert den
Kanal nur dann und nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts herzlich willkommen
benannt wurde sie auch Donnervogel oder
Königin der Lüfte die Concorde brauchte
nur dreieinhalb Stunden von London nach
New York den Todesstoß versetzte ihr das
Unglück im Juli 2000 bei dem tragischen
Absturz nach dem Start am Pariser
Flughafen kamen 113 Menschen ums Leben
alle Passagiere sowie auch die Besatzung
das bedeutete das Ende des Projektes
wohl überhaupt das umstrittenste der
Luftfahrtgeschichte zwar gab es noch mal
eine fluggenehmigung aber 2003 war
Schluss denn von Anfang an war die
Diskussion über die Concorde groß es
ging um den Lärm der Triebwerke und so
wurde es dem überschall-jet verboten die
maximale Geschwindigkeit über Land zu
fliegen das war nur über dem Ozean
erlaubt ein weiteres Problem der
sogenannte Überschallknall ein verdammt
lauter Knall der bei dem
verdichtungsausstoß entsteht wenn das
Flugzeug schneller fliegt als der Schall
in seiner Umgebung die
Schallgeschwindigkeit ist dabei von
verschiedenen Faktoren abhängig wie
beispielsweise der luftdichte und der
Temperatur das verrückte dabei im
Flugzeug selbst ist der Knall nicht zu
hören weshalb den Passagieren der
Concorde immer in diesem einzigartigen
Moment Champagner ausgeschenkt wurde in
einer Höhe von 11 Kilometern liegt die
Schallgeschwindigkeit beispielsweise bei
rund 1060 Stundenkilometern doch trotz
der großen Probleme sind sich
Luftfahrtexperten und Expertin sicher
dass die Überschallflugzeuge schon bald
ein Comeback feiern werden und so
tüfteln nicht nur große Firmen wie
beispielsweise locket Martin oder Virus
an neuen überschallgeräten für
internetkontinental Reisen sondern auf
viele Startups Umwelt und
Verkehrsexperten und Expertinnen vom
International Council on clean
transportation die CCT haben jetzt eine
Studie veröffentlicht nach der bereits
im Jahr 2035 etwa 2000
Überschallflugzeuge unterwegs sein
werden und das tatsächlich an Flughäfen
weltweit wie beispielsweise Dubai London
heatio Frankfurt und New York und 160
Flughäfen werden in diesem Szenario von
den Überschallflugzeugen angesteuert
teilweise mit mehr als 100 Staats- und
Landung pro Tag bei der Entwicklung
vorne mit dabei ist beispielsweise
Boeing der Konzern hat im Sommer 2018
das Konzept für den sogenannten
hypersonic Jet vorgestellt dieser soll
mit fünffacher Schallgeschwindigkeit
fliegen in der Fachsprache auch als Mach
5 bezeichnen hierbei ist die machtzahl
eine dimensionslose Angabe der
Fluggeschwindigkeit konkret zeigt sie
das Verhältnis der Fluggeschwindigkeit
zur Schallgeschwindigkeit in der
Umgebung diese fünffache Geschwindigkeit
des hypersonic Jets wäre Wahnsinn wie
der Vergleich mit der Concorde zeigt die
schaffte damals maximal mach 2,2
tatsächlich also eine Art superflieger
und so wird die Entwicklung sicherlich
auch noch einige Jahre in Anspruch
nehmen bis zu 30 Jahren werden wir wohl
noch darauf warten müssen so die Angaben
von Boeing selbst anders dagegen sehen
die Pläne des us-start-ups
boomtechnologies aus schon 2020 also
nächstes Jahr soll die ouvertür in
Betrieb gehen wenn auch nur mitmacht 2,2
zu den Investoren des Projekts gehören
beispielsweise Google Airbnb und Dropbox
die Vision des Unternehmens Passagiere
für rund 2000 Euro in rund 3 Stunden von
London nach New York bringen bei der
Concorde kostete dieser Luxus damals
übrigens umgerechnet 16.000 Euro auch
das Unternehmen Airbus ist beim Thema
Überschallflugzeug mit am Start und
entwickelt derzeit den businessjet AS2
schon 2023 sollen ein Erstflug
stattfinden 2025 könnten dann erst
einmal bis zu 12 passiert Passagiere
abheben später sollen dann deutlich mehr
Passagiere transportiert werden können
doch es gibt auch staatliche bemühen
Überschallflugzeuge wiederzubeleben im
Frühling 2018 machte die US
Weltraumbehörde NASA ernst und gab einen
Überschallflugzeug in Auftrag und zwar
wurde der Rüstungskonzern locket Martin
beauftragt einen Prototypen des
sogenannten X-Plane zu entwerfen zu
bauen und zu testen etwa 200 Millionen
Euro ist der NASA das Wert der Plan
x-plan soll in 16 000 km Höhe fliegen
und zwar mit
1.500 km pro Stunde seine spezielle
Bauform soll den lauten Knall verhindern
und zwar indem die Schallwellen nicht
miteinander verschmelzen sondern in
kleine Stücke zerteilt werden die
Bezeichnung des Designs quit supersonic
technology damit können die Jets dann
direkt nach dem Start in den Überschall
Modus geben damit würde dann sogar die
Reisezeit noch einmal verkürzt werden
eine Miniaturversion des neuen
nasa-überstand Flugzeuges wurde schon im
Windkanal getestet im Jahr
25 soll dann das endgültige
Passagierflugzeug mehrere Tests
durchlaufen für die Bevölkerung auf der
Erde soll es nach Nase Angaben dann im
besten Fall nicht lauter sein als das
Zuschlagen einer Autotür oder ein
Donnergrollen Umweltexperten und
Expertin sind dennoch pessimistisch sie
waren davor dass viele Länder darunter
auch Deutschland mit regelmäßigen
überschallknalls rechnen müssen die
Region rund um die Flughäfen seien durch
den extremen Lärm bei Staat und Landung
dann unbewohnbar naja aber dann würde
natürlich ein Verbot greifen hinzukehren
nach Angaben der aktuellen ecct-studie
100 Millionen Tonnen zusätzliches CO2
und das ist wirklich ein Problem das
würde in die erdmatmosphäre gelangen
pures Gift für das Weltklima also und so
fordert die Non-Profit Organisation dass
ich die Unternehmen und Hersteller der
Überschallflugzeuge schon jetzt auf
Umweltstandards konzentrieren könnten
wir einen Weltraum aufzubauen klickt auf
dieses Video mega spannendes Thema bei
dr Watson unbedingt anschauen und
abonnieren bis dann
bleibt